what do you make of this guy stewie2k
uh it's a very high-risk high-reward
pickup
i don't know if stewie2k is necessarily
the best
fit for this team
there's a very good chance he will not
become some fantastic player
he will not become the player that will
help kanan become a better team and they
will not be as good a team as they were
in the summer when they made those three
finals as well so i don't think it's a
good pick up
being in a disadvantage but look at that
stewie's always out of the mountains he
gets a triple
takes down all of this really a little
bit of hesitance going back in but now
stewie
it's the trademark pop flash through
let's see how many you can get one two
swings for the third
and stewie dominates the play and
stewie's gotta go huge here one for him
two
three and four stewie destroys the
entire push
oh my god what the [ __ ] stewie's on his
head but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie
[Applause]
to save them the only man that could
jake stewie2k yip was born on january
7th
1998 and grew up in san francisco
california
but young stu's childhood wasn't easy
his parents spent most of their time
overseas
and since his siblings were so much
older than him he was raised by his aunt
until her health pushed her out of
stewie's life
growing up i always lived with my aunt
because my parents would work
out of the country but eventually mom
got cancer but
she's okay now my mom would come back
monthly and my dad will come back during
the big holidays
by the time he was in high school his
friends were at different schools
and his siblings were off to college he
was on his own
and turned to video games to fill the
time
stewie discovered cs go in the summer of
2014
when he was 16 years old and he was
instantly hooked
the more i played cs go the more
attached i got to the game
i thought it was like a really cool game
and i thought like
it was a pretty fun game to learn so
when i watch like streamers like i used
to watch mike play a lot
and i see him do certain
aim like a certain way to aim then i
would try to mimic it
i would try to like steal people's place
out and just like add it to my own
but his obsession came at a price
stewie was getting into 10 man pickup
games on esea
and playing into the night like his
heroes on stream
which meant he had to sleep in which
meant
he missed school which meant he stayed
home
and played all day long and missed
school the next day
cs go was his drug of choice he couldn't
stop playing and
it was tearing his life apart at that
point
his grades were slipping and his school
told him he either had to come back
or transfer i missed like weeks of
school and then eventually
my school would contact my mom and my
mom would fly back and
make sure i'm starting to go to school
but i still go to school but my grades
aren't good i'm not doing homework
my test scores aren't that good my
parents never understood esports
and always thought that being on the
computer was a waste of time
so when they would get contacted from
school about me being absent they would
confiscate my computer
without a computer stewie couldn't play
cs go and
missed practice sessions with his
amateur teams
but was still dedicated to the game he
didn't see a future in class
but he did see one when he was playing
cs go
stewie knew about the world of
professional cs go
and wanted to land with a stable team
especially if that team
was cloud9 he looked up to what was
often considered the best cs go team in
north america
and he believed he had what it took to
get on their roster
well i always wanted a chance even when
you guys picked up ryan
i honestly thought that i should have
gotten that chance
but i would probably i was probably yeah
no but no one knew who i was but
i always thought that i could bring more
to the table than any other pickup
c9's then manager stunna kept in contact
with stewie though
he saw potential in him he knew the pug
star could shine
on the big stage stewie knew that
getting noticed
would require endless hours of grinding
he even snuck out of the house one day
to play in the rgn pro series lan
in 2015 which was his first experience
meeting fans well the first fan
interaction i had was at
rgn land that's the line i snuck out to
so that was pretty cool when people
asked me to
sign their gear stewie got his first
taste of csgo fame
and it only made him want more he threw
himself
into the game but all the while his
family's respect for him
bottomed out at that point my dad and my
mom kind of like you can tell like
they're giving me the cold shoulder
and they're like not really listening to
what i say they're letting me do what i
want but they're not happy about it
but they're like not paying full
attention to me
and that's when he got the offer one day
i was practicing and then i got a call
from
trace and then i picked up the phone and
then he said
that he's gonna give me a three-month
contract
but really it was like a full contract
that one of you guys had
but i guess it was a light a fire under
your butt
yeah pretty much and then that's where
it all happened he just i didn't even
get a try out and i just got
a spawn on the team but stewie waited at
17 years old
his parents would have to sign off on
his burgeoning cs career
something he knew they'd never go for he
wanted to wait until he was
18 to be able to do this on his own and
one of the
one of the things i had to consider is
like i had these other players i was
talking to
and i needed to basically have faith in
him that he wouldn't sign with another
team
when he turned 18 which was a few weeks
away and i needed to basically commit to
him
turn down the other players i was
talking to and wait for him to turn 18
and on his 18th birthday like sometime
after midnight he signed his contract
with 5 9.
stewie moved to the c9 house shortly
after
without a word to his parents that
chapter of his life
was closed and he was ready for his shot
at stardom
he was ready to finally succeed at
something
but the pundits didn't think he was
worth anything
he's someone who's shown no tactical
aptitude whatsoever
seems to have also shown no
self-awareness as a player because he
hasn't improved any of these key areas
where he was having issues
i don't know if stewie2k is necessarily
the best
fit for this team but i think stewie2k
is a really good player
and it just i don't feel like it's the
right team for him that's all it is
[Music]
god this is the worst attack ever
it's a miracle that you're able to just
run in like that and get a kill it's
honestly it's a miracle there's a very
good chance he will not become some
fantastic player
he will not become the player that will
help canada become a better team and
they will not be as good a team as they
were in the summer when they made those
three
finals involves i don't think it's a
good pick up the moment cloud9 announced
that they had signed
stewie2k to replace shawn gares one
question was on every cs go fans lips
why i'm not trying to be an astronaut
but
of all the young and uprising talent
then they why the hell stewie 2k
one map one map uh that's fine well good
there
who else who do you think is better
that is a
seriously i'm curious what you guys
think
because if you don't think stewie2k was
their best pickup then
i you really just don't know the scene
stewie wasn't some n a superstar
he was a pug player known for making
flashy individual plays
armchair analysts took to reddit and
hltv to laugh at c9's decision
and puzzle over why they'd sign a
complete no-name but stewie persevered
at the start i did get a lot of haters
and a lot of people who
discredited what i like to do over time
i think
when i started showing potential that's
when i started to have
a little more support from fans and a
little more support from other players
as well
his first months with cloud nine were
rough the team wasn't winning anything
and bombed out of the mlg columbus major
but it's gotta go they have to go right
now there's a kit
only on shroud smith staring it down
it's going to be rpk with stewie it's
all on shroud one versus four and g2
they'll do one better than envy no less
but it's cloud9 once more that get
completely
dismantled in a major after that the
team brought on slimy as an igl
to take some of the pressure off of
stewie it didn't work out
the bomb is about to go down and trying
to make his way around the corner here
stewie gonna go down shroud
in a one-on-one nitro spraying furiously
he just has to hit
really anything at this point here and
it's going to be the kill 16 10.
i don't know if it occur but now they've
got the upper hand that's pulled back
again though as
shroud and stewie are able to collect it
it's got to be set this once more of
course same position he was in last time
they are locking the deagle oh look at
the hp
oh very well be in here for cloud nine
and nothing gonna get a killer return
now up to 31c it's gonna be taking down
stewie still a three on four right now
they need that bomb plant skadoodle
fighting close to the statue
but he's gonna leave slemmy alone here
to fight one on three
no bomb plant and they know he's down
there somewhere going for the kill not
gonna happen it's 16 14.
slemmy was out by august and while
automatic replaced him on the roster
it was up to stewie to step up as igl
everyone always thinks he's some flashy
player who wants the highlights and they
like to criticize him when he doesn't
have a big performance but
being his teammate i realize stu loves
to win and he actually when he strat
called was pretty unselfish a lot of the
calls he didn't
always want to put himself in the best
position and that's when i started to
gain a new respect for him as a player
i feel like he didn't really realize
until joining this team until he was
forced into like an igl role in a sense
that he's really good at it and i i just
don't think
that would have happened on any other
team that might have you know
put yeah no other team would have pushed
him to do that so i feel like
he's really he's a really good igl and
he's only going to keep getting better
with stewie in charge c9 was popping off
in north america
and picking up impressive placements
internationally
but the pressure was back on stewie and
he finally proved his worth in brazil
at the esl pro league season four finals
now the one thing about dropping through
is they could push to be as a result but
they want to contest stewie
who gets one it's called zero bomb down
automatic in a one versus one and he's
got no idea where automatic is
he's rotated all the way to long and
cold might get caught
he's looking down toward the door he's
in the open it's automatic
to give cloud nine season four
and that duo of stewie or rather stewie
and automatic
together on cloud9 is what brought them
back to form and they show it in the
last round to clutch it back
the rise of stewie this year has been
the biggest cloud9 story
and when i have talked to him about the
work that he's put in it's unbelievable
how much he's deserved at the demo
watching and everything
absolutely a meteoric rise from from
stewie this year
turned to be from you know people that a
lot of people question
his addition to cloud9 whether he was
the the right choice for them but
he turned out to be the in-game leader
of the team the playmaker
and the leader in general so an amazing
all-around performance from him
c9 brought down optic gaming mouse
sports and sk gaming
for stewie's first big win but if
everything came together in brazil
it didn't stick together for long gets
behind coverage without taking any
damage but this is such a hard position
instantly scopes on apex though one more
to go onto kenny but kenny could just
hold this forever if he wants to
peeks out back behind coverage again
skadoodle takes the shot and that's
gonna seal the deal
g2 he's gonna be on the flank fine
shroud picks back around and two one two
two one taps he's gonna close out the
map like that
absolutely dominating cloud9 there but
up above is stewie with everything to do
the eighth
to save cloud nine here or it's a gambit
victory and the tag
oh my god and the bomb he's going for
the block
oh my god he went for the plum stew is
so close
four kills how much more can he do yeah
c9 looked better at esl one cologne
where they made it all the way to the
grand finals but were utterly dominated
by sk
this could be the final play of the
tournament cloud nine trying to do what
they can as they edge towards the b
side problem is now where they're so in
the open even if they threw one they'd
be able to push through it before it
landed
based on the angle it's thrown so phelps
could go he doesn't even need to wait to
go they walk into it it's lined up and
it's done
3-0 in the grand five five best of five
grand finals excuse me
and then everything fell apart at the
krakow major
connector makes it really hard for
schedule to maneuver leaving nothing
alone it's nothing
between versus pro and playoffs
can he do it though all the experience
as much experience as the
veterans of vp but no it's going to be
vertus pro
cloud 9 went into full rebuild mode
dropping long-time members
shroud and nothing for tarik and rush
still stewie was hopeful i think the
team has a lot of potential i think the
ceiling is way higher than with jordan
and trout
i'm not taking any credit away from them
but i think we have more potential with
this team just because we got a lot more
younger players now we
mesh together really well our
personalities don't clash we
talk things out when we have problems
stewie's star power was there
but he still didn't have that huge win
he had come so close
so many times but just couldn't get it
done when he needed to
taric was moved to igl and for a while
things didn't look too bad
cloud9 wasn't winning but they were
getting far
unfortunately they were stymied at every
turn by one team they've got a long road
still and plenty of opposition
rain gonna be the first one up and he's
been so stellar there's no stopping him
he doesn't
miss a beat great hedge fund now he gets
aggressive but kerrigan takes it out for
him and actually it's
all the kills coming it's so quickly
faze clan
they stroll their way into the grand
finals here at esl one new york
he's through the window i thought he was
still running by good fine from rush but
nico immediately responds bomb plant
ensues and skadoodle with an office
going to try and watch over
he's actually going to the m4 he wants
to crawl he wants to close the up hasn't
been amazing for him he's given his
position oh wait
what is that how what a way to close it
phase 2-0
cloud9 gone liquid gone is the first one
up and
he's able to find that shot right to the
face he can move forward and go for the
clutch
versus two but time is so incredibly low
rain catches him off guard from short
and phase they've done it they're going
to win this series out 2-0
and they will be heading through to the
grand final tomorrow
faze were a super team built to win
majors and dominate the competition
and leading up to the boston major they
were certainly living up to their
reputation
the team placed second at iem oakland
the esl pro league season six finals
and first in the ecs season 4 finals
they might not have been shoeins but
faze entered the boston major as
tournament favorites
while cloud9 were just another n a team
hoping for a better than average
placement
you can kind of compare us to phase
we're not as good as them right now but
they have five superstars and i feel
like we have five superstars as well
they don't look like they're gonna go to
the top ever but they're like one of the
few teams that i actually appreciate in
as much as they do take care of the
teams that are below them
all the teams below the rankings you
could usually put your money that cloud9
will beat them but then they'll lose
the ones above it's rare you get
consistent teams like archer
c9 went undefeated in the majors new
challenger stage
but things got rockier when they hit the
new legends stage
beat this push there is the peak there's
the flashback very important outcome
santorus gets nothing
down to pass picks rush out the air now
another one from paz
what else could he oh my goodness paz
fought from him
absolutely unbelievable there from him
oh my god the
ace to take the match this was a tough
one for me because i
sort of picked up both teams as dark
horses i really didn't want them to meet
but uh space soldiers getting the better
of that one cloud9
really got to pick themselves up if they
want to get to boston these are the
standings you can see cloud9
all the way down there in the doldrums
right now crazy crazy stuff cloud9
needed to win three in a row
to make it to the bracket they brought
down virtus pro
two versus four snacks and pasha doing
all they can
no weapon for them to collect plays
through the smoke automatic
hearing them executing snacks and
there's the last player patcher in the
red
there he goes and there they go virtus
pro have been eliminated from the major
and cloud9 are fighting for survival
yesterday after the space soldiers game
you tweeted that your confidence was
at an all-time low but today that's not
what we saw at all you were playing with
a lot of confidence so
what happened between yesterday and
today how did you reset yeah
yesterday i don't know why but i just
wasn't really focused on the game space
soldiers so today i just kind of came
out with the killer mentality and just
kind of
overpeak astralis so they put themselves
in position where they can get some
information they can quickly rotate to
each bomb site
both of them with eyes on a oh they
spotted him they definitely knew and
there's the kill 16-6
australia set packing from cloud9 who
continue into the tournament they're
going to play later today
to see if they can finally make the
playoffs and vegas squadron bomb will be
planted
comes in through the vent right now
won't be there in time to
deny the plant get spotted by one though
he could do this but he's got no kip
no nades and he's got to find two kills
which are played plenty polar opposites
yeah entirely 180 again though the hpi
jumps across rush nails at 16.
rounds for cloud nine and one final
legend status spot for skadoodle cloud
nine into the top eight
not to mention they came back from zero
and two we've had a couple teams where
we've talked about if you're going to
qualify the major avoid elimination
whatever it might be you have to have
your stars
kind of step up and just say flat out
i'm going to qualify and stewie did that
here
today with those three wins c9 made it
back to the bracket
and they were determined not to let it
go to waste
c9 were set to take on g2 in the
quarterfinals
but what followed would be better
described as the stewie show
and body doesn't want to push into the
side he knows it's all on this round
he hears it apex stepping a little bit
too soon
now body in so much trouble but kenny's
gonna be on the high ground getting the
kill
he almost went down himself there's body
picking it up and now it's a one versus
one
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in there and stewie picking
up that kill
and cloud9 are in the semi finals oh my
god what a story they shut down g2
almost flawlessly next was sk gaming
a tournament favorite and one of the
best teams in the world
with everything on the line cloud9 and
stewie
knew what they had to do stewie is still
here there's still a chance
fern's going to walk right into it at
the time a double
he's done it still he's created a chance
there's a shot through the wall
and close range is automatic with the
mp9 shutting down a couple of s3 lining
up the kills
what can you even do about that now the
flash bang comes out but they do rush
down fallen
that's going to be a lot of trouble as
fur gets down as well cloud9 answering
back twice as hard
taking down automatic with the kill
and just like that clown nine in a one
versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds
and cloud9 are in the grand finals of a
major tournament
on the other side of the bracket another
tournament favorite was tearing through
their competition
young estonians first time in the
playoffs he's certainly impressed
but it's not been enough the mouse has
bit the cheese the trap is closed two
nothing for faze they'll move through to
the semi-finals
now it's a two or two where nico is
still alive still trying to make up the
mistake made earlier
one versus one and that's more like it
from nico
great read from zeus to hold off as well
because he knew ct was killed
so the vent was nest lifeless likely i
should say what a shot from guardian
words out of my mouth
as he nails it through the box he is
tagged up smoke on the ball immediately
he's got the kit
doesn't elect to hold on to again he's
got time to play with and two for two
smoke will do
it's phased to the final and guardian is
an absolute god
faze clan had dropped a single map in
the new challenger stage
and made it all the way to the grand
finals without dropping another
they looked unstoppable and analysts
pegged them
to win it all this is the final boss
this is the phase roster just look at
this talent it is so
stacked because if you look at meetings
this year when they played each other
you can see cloud9 have certainly not
had the best of it
faze clan seem to be their kryptonite i
think the problem here is the fact that
you know faze not only won the last
three encounters in the best of three
two and oh it's
in such a dominant fashion as you guys
can see only double digits two times
cloud9 is playing super well but faze is
the favorite here
and they're going to play like it but
stewie2k's cloud9
had a different plan the first map was
close
to short that's information away
that was maybe the only chance but
guardian comes back in oh god if he gets
two
there's still more to go though cowboy
must plant the bomb the peaks come in
but guardian
will not stop one more to go and
guardian
gets them all
quite the money-making mission he's
going to destroy them all down with the
mp9 money in the bank first good doodle
this is absolutely the smoke's going
away and now it's olive by some of the
sniper
there's guardian automatic on his own
running up the short position i think
all of might have heard him
which means that they can all hold
angles the smoke fake the flashback
won't work
out faith clan take the first map of
this series
but cloud nine were ready to fight back
they were close in the first round
and they came in swinging on faze's map
leaving astralis
tarik as well he's got a lot of proof
and he's trying to do so
relentless aggression doesn't matter
what the situation oh that's dirty but
it is from street uk
so they're getting picked off one by one
and there's dewey there's his position
coming into play
getting whittled down picked apart piece
by piece until there's nothing left
cloud9 10 rounds faze still
stuck waits patiently
that is phenomenal downtown making it
work
map two in the bag and now they're back
in it the underdogs took overpass
16 to 10 and with the home crowd behind
them
cloud9 had shown that they had what it
took to take maps
off phase now they just needed to win
he's going to stay alive now 10 seconds
for this bomb to go down he must stay
alive stewie
is going absolutely crazy on the b bomb
site there's no time to fly the bomb
it's too late the money's not there one
more round
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back stewie's on his own but look at the
time
look at the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
it's no more play
stewie's
[Applause]
to save them the only man that could the
only man in position
never wavering never faltering
repositioning after the first frag is
both now from quad here for phase
can cloudline close it skadoodle gets
one skadoodle can't get the third it's
nico with 12.
is there time though is there time i'm
not sure if there is going to be a close
one
and he's done it can make the play just
by staying there he's a threat
oh my goodness it was all too
classic my god
do you know what that noise means that
it means it's match point cloud nine
do they have enough to take over the
line this time it's guardian versus two
can he do it again he's in this position
before to win phase
around a very important very crucial one
can he deny cloud9
saw from this position before he cannot
miss
a single shot guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened they made it work cloud
[Applause]
with that win cloud9 made history
becoming the first ever north american
cs go major champions
but that trophy meant more than just a
victory for n a
it was a victory for every player on
that team
it was a victory for stewie and how
about this boy
such a struggle to even get to play
professional counter strike in the first
place
and now he is a major champion for
stewie
the kid whose family never supported him
the kid who defied his parents to go pro
the kid who dreamed of one day suiting
up for cloud9
this was everything it was proof that
signing him
wasn't a mistake it was proof that he
was one of the best cs go players
in the world but being on top means
fighting to keep your spot just a few
months after winning the major with
cloud9
stewie left for sk gaming the promise of
competing with one of the world's most
accomplished teams
was simply too enticing fallen has
always been pictured as
a great igl one of the best and cold one
of the best players in the world if not
the best
they came to me last minute and said
uh if i still wanted to join and
i kind of just decided last minute too
there's only two days left and they
wanted me to decide quick so
i had to put all the pros and cons
together and just kind of compare it
together but
sk has struggled since adding stewie
the team is on shaky ground with unclear
leadership
and a new player that doesn't speak
their language but
they have stewie his firepower his
potential
and his drive to turn his losses into
fuel for victory
stewie is still young and his future is
still open
with one major trophy under his belt he
has to be looking
for another
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button